this philosophy which is that the
constitution is
basically either a tool or an obstacle
on behalf of left-wing viewpoints that
is now being promoted openly
by cnn again your objective at name and
news they put out a report today it's
titled trump administration issues a
racist school curriculum report on
martin luther king
jr day okay first of all this is part
and parcel a broader effort by the left
to suggest that republicans can never
quote mlk
right if you say that martin luther
king's dream which was that people be
treated as individuals
rather than as representatives of their
race if you say that that is a very good
thing and it's a good thing that america
celebrates that ideal
the left will say no no we need
ideological homogeneity in order for you
to quote mlk antenna hosting is
representative of this view
on the left if you want to cite mlk
approvingly for that sentiment you also
have to buy
into all left-wing tropes and if you
voted for trump you are simply not
allowed
to believe anything that mlk believed
her sonny hosting doing this routine on
abc's the view
i saw today unbelievably unbelievably in
my in my view
ted cruz kaylee mcinerney uh rona
mcdaniel melania trump
quoting dr king tweeting dr king those
were the same people
that were like melania trump with this
birther live ted cruz
with challenging uh you know the
electoral college
uh you know uh kaylee mcinerney just
over and over again with her propaganda
how dare they
how dare they try to quote
dr king on the the celebration of his
birthday when they
enabled enabled a racist president
okay so this is my favorite part is that
mlk day was supposed to be a unifying
moment around which all americans
could could unify and it would be good
if all of your political opponents cited
mlk approvingly
but if your political opponents cite mlk
approvingly and they are political
opponents and you're on the left
that's very bad then you're not allowed
to talk about mlk ever ever ever again
so anyway cnn
has now come out against what is called
the 1776 report
okay so the the president had an
advisory committee they put together the
1776 report which was designed
to be a counter to the 1619 project and
it is a
fulsome explanation of the ideals of the
declaration of independence
it talks about the greatness of the
united states it says things like this
of course
neither america nor any other nation has
perfectly lived up to the universal
truths of equality liberty justice and
government by consent
no nation before america ever dared
state those truths as the formal basis
for its politics
none has strived harder or done more to
achieve them right that is the basis of
the 1776 commission
and they have it's a it's a report well
worth reading with your kids
it talks about the value of the
declaration of independence and the
value of the constitution
of the united states it quotes people
ranging from thomas jefferson
to frederick douglass it talks about
race in the constitution
it quotes ronald reagan of course and
and the basic idea
is that there are a bunch of challenges
to american principles that are now rife
on the left and this of course is
exactly right it talks about the evils
of progressivism
which held that essentially the
declaration of independence was
irrelevant and the evils of fascism
the evils of communism and then it talks
about racism and identity politics and
points out
that the civil rights movement was a
grand and glorious moment culminating in
the 1960s with the passage of three
major legislative reforms affecting
segregation voting and housing rights
it presented itself and was understood
by the american people as consistent
with the principles
of the founding and martin luther king
jr himself said when the architects of
our republic wrote the magnificent words
of the constitution and the declaration
of independence they were signing a
promissory note to which every american
was to fall air and then says the report
the civil rights movement was almost
immediately turned to programs that ran
counter to the lofty ideals of the
founders
the ideas that drove this change had
been growing in america for decades they
distorted many ideas of areas of policy
in the half century that followed
among the distortions was the
abandonment of non-discrimination and
equal opportunity
in favor of group rights not unlike
those advanced by john c calhoun and his
followers i've written about all of this
i've talked about it on the show
there's nothing racist about this report
cnn's headline is quote
trump administration issues a racist
school curriculum report
on martin luther king jr day so you are
now in direct
opposition to martin luther king jr if
you believe that america was
gloriously founded did not live up to
its ideals and progressively realized
those ideals over time
and that identity politics strips away
those ideals
now you must be banned right you're
you're ostracized you're a racist
if you believe all of those things okay
we're gonna purge our public schools of
these sorts of ideas we're going to cram
down
on american citizens ideas they do not
agree with we will use our institutional
power outside government
in order to do that we will use the
institutions of the media of hollywood
of social media
you'll see it in every area of your
culture you'll see it in your kids
schooling
right this is what the left-wing
authoritarians would like okay and
then they would like to do it using
government itself and then they would
like to formalize this arrangement they
would like to use the powers of the
executive in order to push
all of this stuff forward they want to
weaponize every element of the
government in order to push forward a
left-wing viewpoint
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content